bonjour vous êtes dans sa hotte caddie
notre invité ce matin et georges arnaud
porte parole de l'association culture
égalité bonjour bonjour je suis porte
parole de l'association culture égalité
mais aussi du collectif gymnastes
martinique alors ce collectif prêt
présenter le dites nous en plus objectif
il existe depuis le 8 mars 2008 il est
composé de l'association les amazones
que l'on connaît qui s'occupe du cancer
des femmes a pas seulement des cancers
du sein et du cancer en général des
femmes
nous avons aussi l'association konbit
qui est une association qui intervient
avec le théâtre de l'opprimé auprès des
élèves et aussi auprès de public
d'adultes et nous avons le mouvement du
nid qui est qui intervient sur la
question du système prostitutionnel
auprès des des personnes mises en
constitution alors vous avez fait avec
l'association culture égalité et ce
collectif du 8 mars n'ont pas une
journée de manifestations et de lutte
mais une semaine une semaine pleine
d'intervention et de rencontre car
jeannot le georges arnaud la lutte pour
l'égalité des droits entre femmes et
hommes
ce n'est pas que le que le 8 mars aussi
symbolique soit il avait le 8 mars pour
nom et c'est un temps fort qui nous
permet de bien asseoir les
revendications et notre forme
d'intervention c'est vrai que nous avons
choisi pour ce 8 mars le thème de la
liberté et c'est là la suite pour nom du
travail que nous faisons et avec le
collectif et avec la laine et dans le
culture égalité c'est la
conscientisation des femmes et pour ça
nous avons eu des interventions
différentes des formes d'interventions
différente des publics différents et des
outils différents et c'est ce qui fait
la richesse de ce que nous pouvons dire
maintenant pas alors quel téléphone via
le téléphone qui fait un peu de
d'interférences de vibrations alors soit
folle éloignés ou peut-être le mettre
sur silencieux sais pas si la voilà mais
là ça va mieux
alors on pourra pas donner parce qu'il
ya une liste assez longue d'intervention
bon on va en rave sélectionné
quelques-unes notamment vous avez fait
des interventions auprès des jeunes ça a
été important pour vous en milieu
scolaire oui alors nous avons
entre conte beat culture égalité les
autres associations
nous avons rencontré 800 jeunes et c'est
pas un chiffre qui monte qui gonfle et
nous sommes intervenus dans les
différents établissements scolaires et
avec plusieurs outils tout d'abord en ce
qui concerne combi qui intervient
toujours sur la question du sexisme avec
son théâtre de l'opprimé son théâtre
son théâtre forum et nous avons nous
nous sommes intervenus dans plusieurs
établissements que ce soit dans le nord
lorraine où nous avons commencé très tôt
d'ailleurs aux lorrains avec deux outils
la question du harcèlement de rue le
sexisme la nécessité encore tous les
droits des femmes et sur notre
documentaire sur les rebelles et maroon
alors quelles conclusions au petit os à
votre retour d'expérience oui je dois
tout d'expérience c'est que nous avons
d'abord trouver une grande souffrance
chez certains élèves
c'est à dire que quand nous avons des
élèves et selon le niveau
la classe le niveau social et c'est ça
qui est qui est quand même important des
premiers un défi qui parle peu dans
danser dans ces groupes d'élèves qui
sont des classes moyennes parce que tout
de suite nous sentons surtout quand on
nous projetons notre vidéo sur le
harcèlement de rue nous sentons toujours
une choc parce qu'elle est il y en a
trois qui sortent du lot ou dire oui
voilà ce que nous vivons et c'est sans
permanence alors et la cc dramatique
alors l'harcèlement de rue c'est ce que
c'est oui mais comment elles ne vivent
pas ce que vivent avec beaucoup de
douleur
elles nous disent par exemple est-ce que
je n'ai pas est-ce que mon camp et y
reste quelques pourquoi moi je vais dans
la rue et pourquoi j'intéresse quelques
que je ne connais pas elle nous disait
monsieur qui me dit je veux voir la
faute de ta robe
ce qui veut dire que je n'ai pas le
droit de m'habiller comme je veux et
c'est ça la question de la liberté des
femmes et l'autre qui dit eh ben moi je
lui le monsieur qui n'est pas un petit
copain madame est kepa qui a pas mon âge
mais qui me dit quel âge as-tu judge et
kesa mais moi aussi j'ai 15 ans et c'est
un adulte
donc elles le vivent avec beaucoup de
douleur et aussi de la fatalité en se
disant que c'est comme ça et c'est ça
que nous voulons faire ressortir que ça
ne doit pas être de la fatalité juste
pour ajouter sur la question du regard
sont bien là ça nous permet aussi de
dire aux garçons quel rôle ils ont
dans le harcèlement de rue premièrement
prendre conscience c'est ce que vous
vous adressez au temps au jeune garçon
quand j'ai une musique aux jeunes filles
quand vous allez dans les classes que
nous pensons que ce serait plus porteur
de travailler avec des groupes non
mixtes donc les gars oki 10e
oui je lis en général dont ils disent
ici sa maman je rentre sur lui ou sur la
personne et qui dit mais quand ce sont
mes côtés je ris alors je lui dis si tu
ris c'est que tu cautionnes et là nous
le mettons un comédien vont de longue
date et nous leur disons que ce que nous
voulons c'est qu'ils concret là dans ses
interventions des hommes nouveaux
et ça c'est important pour nous qu'il
réfléchisse et comment ils peuvent
intervenir autrement à l'interaction de
leurs copains oui elle donc toucher la
jeunesse important parce que on se rend
compte que il y a encore beaucoup trop
de deux chiffres en haus finalement
concernant les violences faites aux
femmes des violences conjugales mais les
violences alors physiques ou verbales
etc et on se rend compte que la société
encore par trop patriarcale mais les
élèves les élèves le disent les élèves
le disent ils disent nous sommes dans
une société dans laquelle il y a encore
beaucoup de discrimination réaliser les
les filles envers les femmes
et d'ailleurs nous nous permettons
d'attirer l'attention de l'éducation
nationale parce que ses interventions
que nous faisons sont de la volonté de
chef d'établissement et de professeurs
de documentaliste ce n'est pas une
politique du rectorat de la martinique
et ça on le regrette vraiment et nous
avons l'impression de régresser yeux
caisse sur cette question moi qui étais
chargé de mission à l'éducation
nationale pendant trois ans 3 oh je
trouve qu'on régresse c'est à dire qu'on
n'a pas un pur n'était avancions et et
monsieur carouge il de bêtes massif ce
plan d'intervention
parce que vous parlez le chiffre de 2
des violences nous on a pu donner dans
ses interventions direction des élèves
que nous pouvons prévenir ces violences
et ne pas être dans cette catastrophe
dans laquelle nous sommes dans ce pays
là et ce n'est pas des chiffres qui sont
du seul manque au vide parce que le
procureur attire l'attention des attire
notre attention depuis très longtemps
sur ces chiffres des violences faites
aux femmes
alors nous avons par exemple en france
nous avons une amp sur 1000 e
en proportion une victime sur 73 pour
mille hommes en martinique sé 3,55
donc elle désire plus du double du gué
la guadeloupe et la martinique sont les
départements français où il ya le plus
de violence où on a à peu près 950 emile
procédure par an dans sachant qu'il ya
un fait sur dix qui fait l'objet de
plaintes et en même temps donc en
moyenne on voit qui à peu près 30 femmes
qui sont victimes de violences et là
nous sommes en pleine préparation des
élections régionales
nous disons que les candidats les
candidates droit ve avoir ces chiffres
en tête
ils doivent s'en saisir cette saisie
fait proposer quelque chose qu'on
faisait et nous avons des propositions
par exemple nous disons que par exemple
la ctm les collectivités qui ont charge
la question de la formation
professionnelle doivent mettre de façon
obligatoire un module sur la question
des violences et de l'égalité hommes
femmes dans leurs dents ont collé dans
les programmes en direction des gens
parce que c'est là qu'on rencontre les
femmes et contre les hommes donc que
nous pensons que cette campagne quand la
vie est de 8 mars nous confirme sur nous
confirmait vraiment que la question de
l'intervention auprès des femmes est
importante et nous l'avons vu dans le
flash mob et dans la paix dans
l'intervention théâtralisée que nous
avons fait sur sur la place publique
nous avons cette intervention les femmes
le ressentent avec une émotion elle
pleure sur la place publique quand elle
voit lé texte que nous avons écrit dans
notre journal que nous que nous
présentons ce journal que nous avons que
nous avons rédigé bain ces femmes ne
disent mais c'est ce que nous vivons
c'est à dire quelle est notre espace de
liberté et d'ailleurs le vous dites que
vous voyez parfois même des
transformations physiques en quelques
jours en une semaine enfin vous et chez
les jeunes femmes exemple jouer au jeu
des jeunes ce que nous avons de plus en
plus de jeunes femmes avec nous les
femmes qui ont joué ce ses pieds
théâtralisée j'en ai vu ni un soir elle
était métamorphosé et elle a donné son
témoignage
mais en rond ça en est en jouant cette
ces réalités qu'elles vivent tous les
jours et en pouvant en l'exprimant on se
transforme et c'est ça l'objectif de nus
collectifs une masse et de la culture
égalité c'est d'amener à cette
transformation des femmes pour
on soit dans une société égalitaire
alors pour conclure de ce point de vue
en étant réaliste en restant réaliste
est ce que vous voyez aussi quelquefois
le verre à moitié plein est ce qu'on
peut dire qu'il ya eu quand même allé
quelques quelques évolutions quelques
progrès quelques évolutions dans nos
logiciels dans nos mentalités dans notre
cas les choses les choses avancent et on
ne rit plus comme par les violences
faites aux femmes même temps personne ne
rit c'est pas politiquement correct de
dire bon mot avec coolio monde et et
hénique a pas bon habillée comme ça
suffit parce qu'on est quand même dans
la culture du viol toujours un dans ce
pays là qu'on n'a pas parlé du viol n'a
pas parlé de l'inceste qui est un qui
sont des choses très très importante de
nos pays et le viol les gens on ne brise
pas le silence est notre objectif
aussi dans cette conscientisation chez
les femmes dans cette dans ce qu'on
appelle la pouvoir manque c'est à dire
reprendre confiance en elle mais t'es
quoi you do good bien de boot pour
briser le silence parce c'est le silence
aussi des femmes qui qui permet de ce
point de vue là les langues commencent à
se délier justement que c'est un progrès
qu'on peut noter très doucement traduit
name the en frais minimes ça commence à
venir et nous devons et nous comptons
sur vous d'ailleurs pour continuer ce
travail
merci genre d'ambiance avoir répondu à
bien que si on vit d'avoir donné la
parole merci encore à bientôt
c'est avoue jimmy alors peut-être encore
quelques mots à voix là juste pour dire
que vous serez delà de la mobilisation à
venir parce qu'on n'a pas parlé du 27
février vous au coeur des manifestations
des réunions se prépare il ya sommes
très très proches de la lutte contre
l'impunité contre contre ce non lieu
comme qu'on veut nous donner contre la
prescription contre la presse que deux
champs dans la ferme
d'ailleurs cet après-midi de mai à la
conférence de presse ce qui a lieu à la
maison des syndicats en vue d'une
prochaine action le design d avril
prochain action et nous serons
nombreuses encore avec nos banderoles et
nous appelons les femmes à nous
rejoindre parce que les femmes sont très
concernés par cette affaire
mais si voilà ça y est merci beaucoup
bertrand caruge et merci à georges
arnaud des chiffres cités dont on n'est
pas du tout fier franchement j'aimerais
quoi y'a pas de quoi être fier et je
crois que l'on doit partir en campagne
en marche les violences faites aux
femmes et ça passe par notre attitude à
tous et à tout homme et femme pour faire
évoluer notre attitude à ce niveau là
merci beaucoup bertron carouge on se
retrouve demain ses traditions sur la
première